voyager pendant 48 heures ça peut vous
amener à shanghai ben ali au sydney ça
peut aussi être le temps nécessaire pour
vous déplacer de 3 à gaspé la nouvelle
député de gaspésie les îles de la
madeleine diane lebouthillier il a
appris à la dure
lorsqu'elle a voulu rentrer chez elle
pour noël le 17 décembre son avion
quitte ottawa mais ne peut pas atterrir
à gaspé en raison des conditions météo
elle se pose donc aux îles de la
madeleine où elle doit passer la nuit
le lendemain nouvelle tentative même
résultat si lyon a donc rédigé vers
québec et de la toux les avions sont
pleins pour les trois jours suivants
mais john leboutillier refuse de son
chauffeur l'a répondu en gaspésie ce que
je me suis dit c'est que je vais faire
comme l'ailé si vous utilisez notre bus
parce que le manque de chine où l'eau
c'est un voyage en autobus
la députée ministre prend donc le dos
car au milieu de la nuit jusqu'à sainte
anne des monts
un trajet de 500 kilomètres qui a duré
sept heures et termine ensuite de sa
route en voiture je reste avec déjà des
personnes âgées des personnes qui ont eu
des choix de santé
ces pauvres et même un peu c'est parce
qu'on a on peut qualifier de d'un
service look et qui est acceptable pour
une population et cette aventure a
renforcé sa volonté d'améliorer les
transports en gaspésie john leboutillier
n'exclut pas l'idée d'installer
l'aéroport régional ailleurs qu'à
gastrique
parce qu'il est fréquent que les
mauvaises conditions météo empêchent les
avions de s'y poser et il faut dit elle
au port où les avions peuvent atterrir